hey what is up guys my PhD here and this
is detect that I'm just most excited
about for the rest of this year just for
the rest of 2015 this is a completely
subjective list so your list could be
completely different from mine in fact
it probably is that's kind of the point
no one's gonna watch this video two or
three years from now but I'm really
excited about this stuff now so I'm
gonna get it out there first thing is
the Samsung Galaxy Note 5 we already
know Samsung has the Galaxy S series and
the Galaxy Note series the Galaxy S gets
the updates in the first half of the
year with the newest software features
and a reasonable-sized form factor and
new specs but then in the second half of
the year we get the new Galaxy Note
which tends to have all the software
features that made the galaxy s so
awesome but in a larger form factor that
allows a bigger better display bigger
better camera optics and often a much
bigger better battery the absolute worst
thing about the galaxy s6 edge that I
use as a daily driver right now is the
battery life and we did also late this
year see a samsung galaxy s6 active with
a much larger battery in that big
ruggedized body but I'm still excited
anyway for the note 5
hopefully it'll again get rid of the
Samsung fake leathery materials and
bring back the real metal this probably
also means if it's built like the galaxy
s6 that it will not have expandable
storage and it won't have a removable
battery but if the battery is big enough
I'm ok with that and this is a hundred
twenty eight gig phone so I'm kind of
fine so the second thing on my list is
the oneplus 2 and the oneplus one was
known for being so cheap it was known
for being a super low price budget phone
it looks like the oneplus 2 is not going
to follow in these exact footsteps it's
not gonna be super budget but if it
continues to run near stock Android then
I like what I see here anyway oneplus
has been releasing these teasers of the
specs it's part of their whole marketing
campaign so every couple of days they'll
announce something new about the oneplus
2 so far what we have is the Snapdragon
810 whether it overheats or not will see
the USB type-c port and a fast and quick
fingerprint reader and we've also seen
some other murmurings of you know an
all-metal build and a huge battery and a
quad HD display and I also have one that
you have
Sene announced yet you'll probably want
to keep an eye on Twitter if you're
following me you'll be the first to see
that hashtag hype put this 1+2 is
shaping up to be not really a phone that
one plus one owners upgrade to but more
of a new sort of closer to a normal
flagship and may even have multiple
versions of it we've seen rumors of one
with four gigs of RAM and one with three
gigs of RAM and possibly a mini version
that hit multiple price points it's a
bit more traditional but it's still from
a company that's kind of shaking things
though so the number three thing on my
list is the next Nexus and this is a bit
of a tricky one because we know almost
nothing right now
about that next phone we don't know what
it'll look like we don't know what it'll
be called who will make it all we know
is that it usually comes out around
September October November of the year
that's all we got there have been
rumours that Motorola who made the Nexus
6 would come back and make the next
Nexus and probably make it in a bit of a
smaller form factor then we heard rumors
that LG would come back and bring back a
revamped updated Nexus 5 type of phone
which is even smaller but brings sort of
updated specs and a better camera and
then we've heard rumors that it would be
made by Huawei a Chinese company so I
don't think anyone really knows yet I'm
pretty excited though because no matter
what Google does it's gonna run the
latest version of Android M it's gonna
be a clean stock Android experience it's
probably gonna have USB type-c and it
always seems to sort of shape the
direction that Android will go and it's
sort of a showcase for what the OS is
capable of next up on my list at number
four is the Moto 360 version - when it
comes out and I'm excited about this
particular SmartWatch from Motorola
because we've seen the original moto 360
actually become sort of a pioneer it was
one of the first smartwatches to come
out last year and it was the one that
really got people talking about
SmartWatch design ever since then dozens
of Android wear smartwatches have come
out and they're all pretty similar in
terms of specs and they're all running
near identical software but the thing
that separates them all now is their
design it's how they look on the wrist
some of them are much closer to a
traditional timepiece look while others
gravitate more towards a super sleek
modern look now we have things out like
the Apple watch and pebble time and
things are starting to branch out and
design is starting to shake up a little
so I'm now curious to see what motor was
going to do with the second generation
of their SmartWatch which I'm pretty
sure is going to be coming out in the
second half of this year and last but
not least on my list is the Sony rx100
mark for judging solely by the spec
sheet this thing is everything I want in
a pocket camera
last year I crowned the rx100 mark 3 the
best pocket camera on planet Earth it
has that super high-resolution large
Sony sensor a wide and fast Carl Zeiss
zoom lens great 1080p video really great
photo quality great dynamic range
articulating LCD screen on the outside a
quality viewfinder which is rare for a
pocket camera quiet fast autofocus and
shutter all in a stealthy all-black
aluminum body I've used it a ton and I
love it actually my colleges ultimate
frisbee highlights for the whole season
the season was entirely shot on an rx100
mark 3 so if you want to watch it if you
want to see 60 frames per second
ultimate frisbee highlights then the
link is below that like button the rx100
mark 4 is supposed to be all of that and
then a new processor to enable things
like 4k video and super slow-motion
video at oh I don't know about a
thousand frames per second pretty
excited to test this thing out there you
have it if you thought the first half of
this year was awesome wait till the
second weight to the that doesn't make
sense I didn't think of an outro for
this video that's it thanks for watching
if you have any other things tech that
you're excited for for the rest of this
year feel free to leave it in a comment
section right below that like button and
we can talk about it thanks for watching
and I'll talk to you guys in the next
one peace